a battle cry rings out at the biggest
protest
by farmers mainly from punjab and
haryana
they are getting support across the
country here on the borders of the
nation's capital they are piling up the
pressure
they demand the three laws enacted by
the government
must be revoked
[Music]
so
[Music]
the main concern the farmers say is that
the new laws will deregulate
crop pricing and privatize the
agricultural sector
leaving them vulnerable the government
claims the laws will abolish middlemen
and will give farmers a wider
a deadlock remains as many rounds
between the government and farmer unions
have failed to bring about any results
earlier the police had used tear gas
water cannons
and roadblocks in an unsuccessful
attempt
to stop the farmers reaching the
nation's capital
[Music]
their actions has widened the trust
deficit
even more
denied entry into delhi thousands now
camp on the borders
in their tractor trolleys and tents
there is a concern for the elderly in
these cold conditions
and a raging pandemic medical stations
manned by doctors nurses and volunteers
are
everywhere hot meals served at the many
communal kitchens
play a vital role in sustaining this
protest
something the community is known for
worldwide
this is one of the biggest farmer
protests in recent times
a challenge to the government led by
prime minister modi
for the moment both sides are digging in
neville lazarus sky news at the single
border
delhi